the only thing that can be sure of about
the future isn't it will be absolutely
fantastic it's a pleasure to welcome dr.
dan Cooper from Fermilab in in
Chicagoland area to the into the
impossible podcast which is a podcast as
part of the arthur c clarke center for
human imagination and some exciting news
we were just recently picked up for
distribution using the UC merced
california TV network so this video may
appear eventually on a UC channel near
you which has a huge an audience and
basically millions of people and it's of
course available to the whole internet
so that covers a few dozen people in
sure but it's a pleasure to welcome dan
dan has a new book called at the edge of
condom
he's on a book tour right now happens to
find him in the same time zone as us but
not back to the same state and i thought
we would begin with with a little
introduction to you know who you are
what you do i spend your time and the
kind of work that you do exceptionally
so in terms of bringing science and
education to the public so then tell us
about yourself how did you how did you
get here what's your world line from
today well it's a long and open-ended
question but some a particle physicist
turned astrophysicist i never thought
i'd be an astrophysicist but that kind
of happened by accident i split my time
between Fermilab in the University of
Chicago and my work on things like Dark
Matter and cosmic rays neutrinos and
things like this in terms of outreach
and education stuff like that
one of my favorites of my job is the
teaching and I really enjoyed being in
the classroom kind of take every
opportunity I can to do that
this book the new book is at my third
book so I've been doing this for a while
but I'm particularly excited about this
one I've spent more time with this one
and then spent with the others and I
think me
this is a good way to reach a wide
audience about the sort of work that you
and I do and bringing the all and wonder
of the universe to many people as we can
I'm curious how you got started in
particle physics and then it sounds like
you accidentally were led by your
curiosity of imagination things that we
care about will discuss how do you get
interested in just physics and science
generally speaking when you were a kid
what's your what was that one well did
it didn't happen when I was a kid I know
most of most of our colleagues they'll
have a story about you know in
kindergarten they decided they wanted to
be this specific subfield the scientists
that they are now and all these thing I
have nothing like that I grew up in the
very rural Minnesota not only did I not
think I wanted to be a scientist I don't
think I did the idea what to be a
scientist I just had known encounters or
experience with that I took normal
science classes and junior high in high
school but I didn't find them very
exciting you know physics was rolling
things down inclined planes it wasn't
you know the cool stuff and then I go to
college not for science I intend to be a
music student and I got kind of
disillusioned with that tried a bunch of
other things and eventually wound up
taking a modern physics class and
falling in love with it
so in that one quarter I learn about
relativity a little bit about it anyway
I learn a little bit about quantum
mechanics and these were the two most
interesting things I'd ever heard about
in my life I knew that from the very
beginning there and I suddenly became a
good student because I cared for the
first time and I worked hard and
aggressively and I just kept looking at
these sorts of cool counterintuitive
science physics things from as many
angles as I could
next thing you know I'm in grad school
trying to study particle physics and I
like you said I just kind of my
curiosity and imagination keep pulling
me towards the cosmos the next thing you
know I'm an astrophysicist and the
cosmologists along with
and curious curious as to whether you
completely disconnected your love of
music do you still play music I have
friends in Chicago that are in you know
core choruses and it's all all sorts of
orchestras and there's no shortage of
esthetic activities for you in
Chicagoland so tell me did you were you
playing an instrument do you still play
an in German so I mean I play quite a
few instruments but the one that I
really play is guitar I taught myself to
play on US 15 or so and got pretty good
been in bands throughout my whole life
other than a couple of months here and
there for the last 10 years I played in
a soul band in Chicago called the
congregation that's you're up in the
Chicago area and check us out or for
that matter just use the internet
there's that too yep
so yeah musics always been a big part of
my life but it's a very different part
of my life in science I go out of my way
not to think scientifically about music
I don't want to know how it works or why
it works I want to feel it not think it
and I enjoy using that other part of my
brain mm-hmm yeah that's always forget
we know which brain side I use or not I
know it's only you know I aspire to
someday use 10% of my brain like people
do and not knowing much about music you
know the only instrument I play is the
iPhone but a mutual friend you know Sean
Carroll is a big jazz aficionado or
mutual Sir Alexander is a professional
jazz musician and there is a mark
hemming Kowski another theorist but I
don't know what it is a theorist and
jazz music or soul music but seems to be
a is market musician mark is not a
musician as far as I know but he's a
great aficionado of job okay yeah so so
it definitely seems to be something I
mean dating back looked a giris made
great ancient Greeks and the Stoics or
love to ruminate on the relationship
between physics and music math and music
I feel like a lot of time there's a
little overblown and like you said you
know sometimes you just want to listen
to the music and think about the music
so but it's it's often
there's a book called range it's a new
book where they do a study of cortisone
you know people that have achieved great
heights and all different endeavors
ranging from arts and science to you
know politics etc and they they look at
what are the hobbies of these men and
women what do they do and they find the
most successful you know very strong
correlation between success in the field
whether that's you know my least
favorite thing the Nobel Prize or you
know Pulitzer Prizes or you know
conductors and major symphonies that
they all have hobbies and they have
enthusiasms that extend beyond that and
the social scientists or this book range
of blank eons name might be license I
forget anyway he claims that you know
using the kind of full connectome of
your brain is what really cut the
breadth of knowledge is what allows you
to see new connections so obviously
you're not like thinking about that when
you're you know writing down the new
Dark Matter candidate or praising a
result from the experimental community
but it's certainly not lost on me how
many people have these kinds of passions
that first client seem orthogonal but
but perhaps you don't have this interest
so for you stimulated it but I think
there's another important thing at least
in my experience which is having either
very obsessive personality when I get
into something I get really into
something which helps me to get good at
it so for the same reason that when I
was teaching myself guitar I would play
for six or eight hours a day most days
that later translated into me doing an
awful lot of physics and I think both
things helped me to get good at that
that that trait helped me get good at
both of those things and then so one
thing that we look at in terms of the
artistic connection between you know
science and and the greater human
imagination is a core science fiction we
are affiliated and bear the name of sir
arthur c clarke who was obviously only a
first-rate science fiction author but he
contributed to a lot of innovative
concepts and technology and in science
and you know for us to kind of gateway
drug for many of us science fiction
and introduction to great writers in the
past and you know your book at the edge
of time now available from a Princeton
University Press I believe right they
you have an impressive roster of people
that that have given you blurbs on the
back of your book ranging from Sean
Carroll to my friend and yours
Katie fries in what way - and of course
myself and what I said in this book and
I really believe and I'm grateful I had
a chance to read it I said where
Weinberg Steven Weinberg first three
minutes left off Hooper's at the edge of
time picks up a riveting tour of modern
cosmology told by one of its savviest
guys
Hooper's book takes us on a journey from
our universes formerly inscrutable past
to mesmerizing possible scenarios and
its far future a fascinating story that
is to be savored and I kind of I do see
your book is kind of picking up or
Weinberg's book left off which is you
know obviously I praise but I think it's
Weinberg's an outstanding writer and a
communicator table my favorites yeah and
so I'm curious as to like what were your
influences not you know as I say
Weinberg you know clearly is in this
tradition that you're in
what were the influences that you know
in your life and may not only be
scientific I might be science fiction or
other can you tell us about you know who
are the mentors and people that you look
to in the past so I I'm a you know eager
reader I made a ton ton and most of its
nonfiction but you know quite a bit of
fiction slips in there too
some of my favorite books in my college
years were popular physics books back
then I was a really big fan of Paul
Davies for example he wrote a lot of
books on these things in John ribbon
people like Mitchell Kaku and and you
know Liam Letterman I read all these
things back then Hawking Kip Thorne I
think I read Weinberg bit later does a
little bit later
these days there are a lot of our
colleagues writing really good popular
signs and I read a lot of this a lot of
our colleagues do reading popular
science because they think they know all
the science that's contained
I read it though for how its
communicated because I think we can
become better communicators by by by
seeing how it's done well I joined your
book for example I enjoy you know Sean
Carroll you mentioned I enjoy his
writing a great deal I just read some
stuff from Jan 11 that I think is really
first-rate really exceptional work I
have Joe Duncan's cosmology book on my
shelves for having quite ready yeah but
it says right up there my very short
city list but I really like reading
nonfiction that isn't physics oriented
whether that be biology stuff or
economics or other social science
history I find to be written in a really
different format so I don't know that I
learn a lot about writing from that but
uh social science and not necessarily
physical science I really find helps my
writing to to to did Deepa testa so the
aspect of your writing and the story
it's sort of you know it's sort of
journalistic and that you you know
you're able to weave the other story
that really does take us back you know
to before what was what was previously
hidden I think in the in the writings
there really wasn't a book that filled
in these gaps with enough technical
apologies to my vegan friends but you
know meat on the bone that'ss by you
know like I often will read science
popular science trade books as they're
called because I can blow through them
really quickly because you know I'm
reading Sean's book now or listening to
Sean's book I'm going to interview him
for the podcast in a couple of weeks and
yeah I'm just like fast for I mean I
love Sean and he's a great writer but
you know I I know what the double-slit
experiment is he's I like and he gave me
great advice you know and I was writing
my book I'm like you know do I have the
energy to regurgitate you know the Big
Bang nucleosynthesis arguing you know
and like he already did it you know do I
have to be said he told me great advice
he's like you you can tell it the way
that you want to tell it in other words
you can tell it through your eyes not
that I get the
take my own facts and say you know that
hydrogen formed you know a billion years
ago instead of thirteen billion years
ago but I get to tell the highlight the
important aspects through my lens which
was covered by dust obviously and I I
wanted you know originally to call my
book a brief history of dust but I don't
think that would be really really
possible but what spoke to me is that
you you bring up fully advanced subjects
you know kind of you know the notion of
baryon asymmetry and readers you know I
want readers to read the book because
these are very advanced topics but the
advanced topics are like the analog to
what we want to teach versus what we
have to teach so you mentioned like the
inclined plane so you and I had to teach
the inclined plane that's part of you
know how we get our salary right but on
the other hand we love to teach our
brilliant young students or taking
cosmology or particle physics because
that's close to the boundary of what we
ourselves are learning about and there's
no better way our teaching about there's
no better way to learn something than to
teach it and and you know that all too
well
and what I love about your book is that
you're not you don't shy away from
things like these really you know I mean
compared to the price of you know sliced
bread it's not that important on a daily
basis but you know the baryon asymmetry
the origin of these mysterious things
that may indicate very weighty things
the arrow of time the composition of the
universe the deep you know future of the
universe so I wondered if you could not
you know I hate it when authors are
asked you know can you summarize your
entire book so that nobody has to by the
way yeah I want people to read this book
because I think it's it was a really
fast read for me and it wasn't because I
knew everything in it quite the contrary
it was very interesting to hear you know
from a perspective of somebody who
wasn't isn't a native astrophysicist as
you're saying but you know what struck
you about astrophysics that caused you
to make a pivot you know in Silicon
Valley speak into you know becoming not
only you know a top-flight performer or
practitioner of of astrophysics but but
to really be able to break it down to
the public what what drove you in that
direction so as a particle physicists
there are really kind of two routes you
can
take particle theorists I should say you
can take the what we call the top-down
road where you maybe study something
like strengths area and try to deduce
how the universe must work from some
sort of grand principle and usually this
involves a lot of mathematics I mean all
of our work involves a lot of
mathematics but this is even more
mathematics and very rarely this is
stuff directly connect with experiments
I learned pretty early in grad school
that's not what I wanted to do I just I
I like I like knowing that in three
years there's going to be experiment
that tells me that this paper I'm
writing is right right or wrong you know
and usually is wrong okay but I like I
like knowing how we're going to get
closer to the right answer and in string
theory it's not obvious that we know
that on the other hand you can do
particle physics from the bottom up
where you say okay well here's a bunch
of things we've measured some things we
don't understand about those
measurements are the following let's try
to work out theories or models or
something that can explain in those
problems and figure out what experiments
we will do or shouldn't do to find out
if that's right that's much more my you
know kind of MO that's not that suits my
personality quite well but when I was a
grad student you know left had just
finished up left was a the electron
positron Collider at CERN at the time
they were just finishing and the Large
Hadron Collider wasn't going to turn on
for quite a long time so there wasn't a
lot of Collider physics that was going
to happen in the short interim so I
start thinking about other ways to study
particle physics and in particular ways
to study particle physics using the
cosmos so my first project along these
lines was talking about how dark matter
particles might get captured in the Sun
where they would annihilate with each
other to interact to destroy each other
converting themselves into neutrinos and
then we could detect those neutrinos
with big telescopes I was thinking of
the ice cube experiments
and I got pretty deep into that I
learned a lot and got excited about it
and then another dark matter project and
then another dark matter project and
then some neutrino astronomy projects
and then some gamma-ray telescope
projects and pretty soon I looked around
within to my surprise I'd become masters
assistants it was not my plan at all but
given the time in place it was the right
move to do it and now I spend maybe half
my time just thinking about the early
universe which is a great thing to be
doing right now with stage 3 and stage 4
C and B experiments like and then in
gravitational waves and and all these
very exciting things going on telling us
about the first fraction of a second
after the Big Bang I can't help but to
be called in that wreckage can you
explain to the audience why should it be
that these fundamental particles the
smallest things that exist how they
could have any relationship to the
entire universe well I mean the short
answer is the universe is made of
elementary particles and if we
specifically are talking about the the
early universe as you go backwards in
time the universe was hotter and and
denser and the dynamics of hot dense
things are described by elementary
particles so if we go to the core of the
Sun we find a bunch of protons and
electrons in a plasma undergoing those
protons are undergoing nuclear fusion
and I mean these are laws of physics
that following that you wouldn't know
about if you hadn't done particle
physics kind of experiments and if you
go to even hotter environments it's not
just things like protons and electrons
but things like quarks and gluons the
kind of particles we study at a Large
Hadron Collider in fact the kind of
collisions we study between protons the
Large Hadron Collider tell us a great
deal about what the universe was like a
trillionth of a second after the Big
Bang when it was full of all the
particles that we study at the Large
Hadron Collider and the way we know
about the laws of physics that dictated
those early moments of our universe's
history we basically know that because
we carry out experiments and particle
accelerator environments like large hmm
right yeah the universe
as an accelerator you brought that up or
you mentioned that and I think that's
something that surprises folks because
you know it may only be possible to
build an accelerator at most on earth
that has the circumference of the earth
but then after that you have to start
thinking other sorts of designs but then
as you say looking back into the early
universe it was essentially a giant
particle collider the fact that these
wispy most miniscule particles in the
case of neutrinos that you mentioned
earlier that they could perhaps have
something to do with with the structure
of the entire cosmos this is the largest
thing we can possibly ever observe and
so I think that that is a fascinating
thing I often you know a lot of your
book talks about dark matter and it's
not surprising for a particle
astrophysicist what as a human being you
know just sitting around the bar here
thinking about it I mean what is your
level of disappointment or are you not
disappointed you know that that say new
physics is is very difficult to seem to
reveal in that you know we really
discover the Higgs was a monumental
discovery but I think you know
physicists expected and promoted and
hyped up a lot more possibilities than
were actually discovered and I think so
too with the Dark Matter searches that
my colleagues here at UCSD and yours and
Chicago and elsewhere are doing yet
failed to really identify are we looking
in the wrong place I often say you know
to look for the to look for you know
your lost keys you have to look where
the light is but in this case you know
we should you know perhaps we need to
pivot the way that we're thinking about
reevaluate the way that we're thinking
about dark matter
so just personally you know I'm just a
gut-level are you disappointed are you
hopeful are you how do you react to the
to the lacunae that we have seemingly to
identify in terms of what we creeps
expected well yeah of course i'm i'm
disappointed like you asked me 10 or 15
years ago i would have given you a very
enthusiastic pitch about how dark
matters discovery is inevitable
and I would have been happy to take a
bet that we would have discovered the
nature of water by now and I would have
lost that bet in fact I did but luckily
you work in a very prestigious private
school more high-stake that's it but
mostly they had to do it honorably even
when there was something else but but
yeah I mean lots of us were really
surprised not just about dark matter but
the lack of new physics being discovered
at Large Hadron Collider surprised a lot
of us you know there were some people
who who said you know more pessimistic
things but most of us in the community
were pretty sure that when the Large
Hadron Collider was going to discover
maybe supersymmetric particles or
something else that would address a
hierarchy problem or other things but
there was a lot of optimism even an
expectation that by now we would have
discovered all sorts of appearances when
it comes to the dark matter I mean the
arguments we had were based on how what
kind of particle we thought would have
been produced in the Big Bang and the
right quantity to make up the dark
matter and we kind of use some arguments
which okay they're not bulletproof but
they were suggestive saying that the
kinds of particles that would wouldn't
make up the dark matter would be the
sort of particles that we could build
these underground detectors and go and
look for them and we should have seen
them by now and yet they're not there
the experiments have been also like they
performed spectacularly well but no
singles have appeared so in light of
that we're kind of thinking in different
ways I think you use this analogy before
but you know instead of looking under
the lamppost for our keys we're giving
flashlights out and looking in different
places are finding new ways to look in
different places testing models and
theories in it maybe we had thought of
before but weren't our high priority
back then but yeah we're casting a much
wider a net that we used to and I guess
I'm still cautiously optimistic
this is a problem we can solve but right
now I'm not as optimistic as about say
the next five years as I would have been
if you ask me - yeah yeah I mean I do
feel like there is a tendency to kind of
over promise and we do it in our field -
and as experimentalist of what we're
gonna be able to achieve and and it's
not you know dishonest it's really what
we're Street on it's our goal it's what
we're striving to accomplish talk
ourselves into it right yeah you know
yeah the confirmation bias there's this
um hostile sea
I mean people the funniest thing is that
people think you know scientists are you
know bias free and have no prejudices
whatsoever but a cursory look at you
know mo try if we do yeah it's a kind of
wishful self-hate geography but but I do
think you know just getting back into
the the meat of the book you know that
really spoke to me was how you really
are weaving a story that is by its
nature its unfinished a bowl and that we
will not have you know so you whet the
appetite very well but we you know at
the at the culmination of it I find you
know a left with there's a sense of
wonder and you know what we what we are
knowing I think arch of all John
Archibald wheeler said you know kind of
like Sciences is island and you expand
the island into this ocean of ignorance
and as you do that the island gets
bigger but the boundary of ignorance
given me - it just gets bigger a little
bit slower as a slower power but I think
you know the book you know and it's a
positive thing but it's disappointing
cuz it really shows you know how little
we know and looking back into Weinberg's
book forty years ago now and again yours
is so comparable to in many ways you
know one hand it's depressing but other
hand it's kind of exciting to live in a
time you know historians look back at
Copernicus and Galileo they don't even
know about you know universal
gravitation but but they were able to
describe that they weren't discontent
with what they knew they knew there's
probably stuff they didn't know but it
wasn't like as relevant I think to their
daily practice of being a scientist now
we have always know
unknowns and and really I think your
book highlights these things that we
know are true we know there's a very
nice imagery we know that there are
neutrinos we know that there's dark room
we know that there's dark energy we know
the universe is evolving but you know
the why questions and I think that
that's a very tough thing to do and you
do it well and give the reader a sense
of hope but also that the scale of the
challenge is monumental
and I wonder you know as experimentalist
we're kind of singularly focused we're
you know we're designing we're looking
at forecasting modeling simulating
systematics as a theorist you know on a
practical level what is your day-to-day
what are you doing what are you thinking
about nowadays I mean the book obviously
takes enormous heroic amount of effort
what are you devoting your energy
towards now is it exploring deeper the
topics that are at the edge of time or
is it something completely new and
pivoting yet again let me sum of each I
have a personality that likes to take
something really dive deep into it and
then three months later be done with it
and think about something totally
different so I mean just today I had a
couple of meetings with my collaborators
on a couple of projects so I'll tell you
like what today was yeah in one of those
we're talking about classics of dark
matter models that could explain this
thing called the galactic center camera
access this is a signal I discovered
early 10 years ago and it might be from
dark matter particles we don't know and
we are in a very concrete way working
out which models can explain this data
along with some other data it's a very
concrete very bottom-up very almost
pragmatic paper and then the other one
that we're working on different people
different collaborators we are imagining
what the earlier verse might have been
like if there'd been an era where the
entire universe was dominated not by
matter and radiation but by black holes
mm-hmm this is kind of the opposite for
me this is the other extreme this is a
super speculative super far field but it
turns out that it leads to a bunch of
kind of cool observational consequences
somebody can test and we're working out
how these black holes would have evolved
how they would a creep matter how they
would radiate and the way that Stephen
Hawking the start
what kind of gravitational waves would
be produced we're even considering that
they might have produced a background an
observable background of gravitons which
I mean it's not very often that we get
to use graviton in real science that's
almost like it's such a such a far it's
such a difficult thing to ever measure
just for your for your viewers a
graviton would be is a hypothetical
particle that carries the effects of
gravity through space of time the
quantized version of that and you know
most businesses think that this thing
probably exists you know it's virtually
impossible to ever measure one you know
this is this is pretty far afield stuff
but he said that about the cosmic
neutrino back room in the book did I say
that no no I'm joking I'm saying they
said it was impossible to detect the car
they did okay it still is we can see
it's there we can detect it in the CMB
right well you know that of course but
yet it is those particle detection right
when I was the grad student I made a bet
with one of the other grad students
someone's was summer school with that in
50 years we would detect the neutrinos
in the container can we make a bet you
know guy had some action I gotta get in
on this Hooper actually offer me one man
grad school you know a lot of bets with
me to do that it's not a lot of money
especially you see great well were you
were you done with that particular story
then or do you want to follow up on that
or what I wanted to get okay great so I
know you're super busy you've got book
tours and I really appreciative of your
time I want to close with a question
that I asked all people we've had
artists poets science fiction authors
you know we have a great tradition here
at the arthur c clarke center for human
imagination in terms of the amount in
and prolific nature of the artist and
sands and authors and scientists that we
work with I always like to ask these
visitors on the podcast guess on the
podcast the same question
I don't ask it to you now and that has
to do with the nature of imagination of
human imagination and we hear a lot and
and you you know tangentially thought
about this you know spoken about this
online at least on Twitter I've seen but
you know the notion of consciousness the
notion of imagination the notion of
creativity are those things that you
know someone like you who's who's
breached you know many different fields
and unify them together in writing and
teaching and in scientific creativity
can you teach those things in your
opinion you feel and if so how how do
you go about curating cultivating the
next generation of you know Renaissance
men and women if it's even possible in
your opinion so first do you think it's
possible and second you know if so how
so a little separate the break the
question at the tomb Bert's the song I'm
sure that it is in principle teachable I
see no reason why it wouldn't be it's a
task like any other and I'm convinced
the human brain is just a very
sophisticated and complex machine if you
can if the human train can do it then
you can teach or build up machine that
can do it and therefore our brains can
get better but be I just because I think
I'm confident in principle can be done I
don't know how to go about doing it
effect I have not found like with the
grass students I've been but for example
I've been meaningful impact on their
like personality or kind of way that
they approach research I can teach them
scientific facts I can teach a deeper
more clear I can do things like this but
I can't teach them to come up with new
and trade of ideas sometimes it happens
sometimes they just end up being able to
do
and so if they don't I have to
personally been able to find any special
sauce that enables me to that may be
somebody who knows a lot more about
teaching which it or psychology for that
matter could not meet know if you have
any tips although they take them
well I always find an ironic that you
know as professors as you know basically
get thrown in front of you know a bunch
of students and they never really teach
us how to teach they never teach us
about the process of learning and
recently I started becoming on the
process of becoming a flight instructor
- you know supplement the modest income
I get here at the State University at
these you know universities here in
California I'm just kidding I am
compensated fairly and I find it very
interesting and almost ironic that the
federal government spends so much more
time you know imagine an organization
like the IRS you know that has a booklet
and huge huge booklet about the
psychology of pedagogy and you know as
Lowe's hierarchy of needs and all sorts
of things like I never knew as you know
my 16 years of being a professor never
once talking about maybe I missed out on
I know we have resources here I know you
have resources there but but it's
certainly not the case that that seems
to be emphasized at least in the
promotion process and the you know
you're really kind of gauge them in your
papers your grad students your
mentorship on a one-on-one level but not
really on the growth process of as a
gross motor skills those B of pedagogy
so I don't have any you know secret
sauce there although I am learning a
little bit about that and hope maybe I
can report back you know once I get my
first couple of students that's solo in
an airplane might be scary to some
people out there I want to be conscious
of your time I really appreciate you
joining us here on in to the impossible
a podcast of the arthur c-- clark center
for human imagination at UC san diego
and just to give you a chance to do you
know a couple of plugs the plugs zone is
open for you tell people out in on the
internet where they can find you and
where you're going to be in in in
three-dimensional world and
next couple weeks and how to follow you
well you can punch with I angles Dan
Hooper Astro I'm going to be finishing
up this part of my book tour this week
and next week I think it's on Thursday
I'll be at the seminary co-op bookstore
in Chicago
and then there's some other things in
2020 scheduled and I just encourage
everybody to check out the book at the
edge of time exploring the mysteries of
our universes for seconds and let me
know what you think I'm easy to find on
the internet so I welcome all
constructive criticism or comments great
I mean I compliments or are never to be
turned away well then thank you so much
both for your conversation and your
wonderful new book and I definitely
encourage folks to look for it I will
leave the links to it and to you and the
description for the podcast and the
YouTube videos so thank you so much for
joining us down enjoy the rest of your
tour thanks Brian I really appreciate it
thanks for that chance
[Music]
the only thing we can be sure of about
the future is it will be absolutely
fantastic
[Music]